we've been doing this Jenga tower thing
for a while the way we've been doing it
is that for every two people that make a
contribution at patreon.com slash david
pakman show I move one piece when we
finally have the tower fall whatever
number of pieces I've been able to move
we double it and it becomes a membership
discount right now I have moved 26
pieces meaning if it were to fall after
the next move we would have a fifty-two
percent discount code for membership we
have three more moves to make today
no wait yes there any more moves to make
today and I don't know that I have any
moves I'm gonna be able to do before
this thing Falls it is very unstable but
Pat please give me the first two names
and I will see if I can make something
happen here
we got KBW and Michael Rudd okay let's
see if there's any piece here and I know
people say David you know you're really
supposed to move the first piece you
touch and all this different stuff
listen I'm trying to get you a bigger
membership discount so don't complain
that I am
maybe cheating in your favor because oh
my goodness this is plane gets herself
to I'm kind of playing against myself I
think I found one here if I'm able to
move this one it would get us whoa this
thing is shaky Pat it would get us to a
fifty four percent membership discount
code man I'm nervous Pat looks very
nervous this can you see how it's
teetering on camera because it this
thing is teetering teetering teetering
whoa and I am placing it on top and that
is now 27 we don't gets us to 54% what's
the next name Alexander millage evitt
and Ryan Richards okay
can I move another piece here let me see
if I can move and oh my goodness this is
just incredibly unstable oh and it is uh
I don't even know what piece I might be
able to move here oh my this is from the
bottom Pat this is from the bottom I
think I found one and I am just very
slowly taking it out and I've almost got
it
I'm just slowly a millimeter at a time
taking this out and I've done it and I
have placed it on top and we are now
down to only four single pieces at the
bottom holding this up I've moved 28
pieces which gets us a 50
6% discount code there's no way what are
the last two names for today Edward do
Jaime and I think it's a lying do hain
yes Edward do Haim and Daniel long Wow
I don't even know where to go I know
people say I should take the pieces from
the top because it's more it's just a
good idea to do that but they are so
locked in and I am just not sure that I
can really do that is there another
piece here that I could move Wow I think
I've got one oh it is teetering and taut
oh I think I'm about to slide it out
look at that got it look at that and
right on top that is now 2028 wait does
that make sense 3 6 9 12 could it be 28
28 29 yeah that makes sense yeah well
could wait no I don't think that that's
right we had 26 27 - no it's 29 that is
29 meaning we are now at a 58 percent
discount I was certain that it would
have fallen by now I was absolutely
certain it would have fallen by now but
it is still standing I thought it was
impossible I didn't think it was
possible to get this far
I really didn't so anyway it lives
another day patreon.com slash david
pakman show by the way we're out of
names so we actually need more
contributions now if we are to move more
pieces tomorrow patreon.com slash david
pakman show tomorrow has to be the last
day alright we should just keep our
cameras rolling 24 hours a day any more
than it's gonna fall at any memory
that's gonna fall yeah okay that is it
let's continue more moves tomorrow if we
have new patreon contributors